Vsauce Kevin here
I'm gonna put this out with my fingers
oh fire
activated my nose receptors pain is
traveling up my nerves at 10 feet per
second into ganglia then my spinal cord
where neurons process the signal and
tell my brain there's damaging stimuli
in my fingers and I knew I knew I had to
drop the match
because it hurt
that scientific explanation fits with
Renee Descartes bell ringer theory of
pain the harder your body pulls on the
bell's hurt rope the louder the pain
alarm sounds in your brain but if that's
true how could Scottish Farmer John
mitson cut his hand off with a pocket
knife and carry it half a mile to a
neighbor's house he said it was sheer
survival and logic and strangely I
didn't feel any pain if a guy can do
that why is my finger still hurt from a
lousy Little Match how can we map
exactly how the nervous system processes
pain and then see fake placebos made of
sugar trick it isn't it interesting that
what hurts you can actually feel
pleasurable to someone else and we can
even feel phantom pain in parts of the
body that have been removed
pain makes no sense
if you think about it
pain is the oldest feeling we have it
predates Love by millions of years we
need pain to protect us from the world
and it's also the bane of our existence
C.S Lewis called pain God's megaphone
and Buddha considered life and pain
Inseparable we seem to know everything
about the mechanisms of pain and
absolutely nothing about how to deal
with it we're in a constant quest to
relieve pain from crafting the way we
live to avoid it to relying on powerful
chemical interventions and life-altering
surgeries to eliminate it but if we took
all the pain away what would we have
left
do we actually need pain to be who we
are well tolerating pain might actually
prove you're human in Dune Paula trades
places his hand inside a mysterious
green box the Reverend mother channels
her energy to subject Paul to intense
unbearable pain if he removes his hand
he's pricked by a poison-tipped needle
and dies but if Paul can overcome the
animalistic instinct to succumb to the
pain that he proves his Humanity it's
the perfect example of The Duality of
pain but instead of nature versus
nurture it's more like nature versus
torture pain is Humanity's original
teacher painful Sensations tell us what
to do less of and what to do more of
according to Dr Frank vertastic plants
don't feel pain because they have no
Behavior to modify and the simplest
organisms like worms don't use any
judgment their behavioral responses are
all pre-programmed so they don't require
instruction from pain but complex
animals like mammals animals with higher
cognition need pain to survive a
caterpillar that loses a leg keeps on
chugging and never even knows it
happened a gorilla that shatters a leg
dies in the jungle what was our first
pain that's easy being born your head
gets deformed to squeeze through
openings that are way too small for it
which is uh tough on the mom too in
terms of evolution the severe pain of
childbirth is probably an incentive to
keep it short we've even deliberately
made childbirth hurt more to speed the
whole thing up the Cossacks of Central
Asia held a mother's hand to a flame for
the duration of Labor Paiute mothers
fasted to starve their babies out
Klamath Indian mothers told their babies
a rattlesnake would climb into the womb
to bite them if they didn't come out and
the strangest source of added birthing
pain came from a tribe in Northern
Russia which forced both mother and
father to discuss details of their
affairs with others during childbirth
but were only born once and mothers give
birth maybe a few times in a lifetime
it's only a tiny fraction of life's pain
as our cognition evolved so did our pain
its frequency its intensity and its
purpose we feel the pain of loss when
someone we love dies we feel the pain
pain of loneliness when a friendship or
a romantic relationship ends we even
feel physical pain linked to our mental
health like the body pain that often
manifests from depression managing pain
and avoiding pain drives almost every
decision we make physically and socially
because we're sufficiently complex to
understand that pain leads to suffering
and that link the link between pain and
suffering is everything including the
words for it the Latin nervous means
chords sinew bowstring but by the 1500s
we understood nerves as Vigor fortitude
energy herophilus of calcidin dissected
enough cadavers to know that there was a
system inside us that generated and
transmitted our Sensations but we had no
real medical understanding of how the
nervous system actually worked until
pretty recently but we knew enough to
use words that suggested we weren't
entirely passive in the process pain
could reveal not just suffering but
strength our initial response to pain is
to completely freak out even to the
threat of pain suffering can happen even
before the pain does the most famous
pain in human history is the
meta-narrative of Jesus's crucifixion he
was likely nailed to the cross through
the carpal tunnel a site which could
support body weight through the unique
strength of ligaments that bind the
carpal bones and the crucifixion of
criminals was particularly torturous
because it slices into the median nerve
that bisects the arm and radiates pain
through the hands shoulders and neck but
Jesus's suffering came by before any of
that even happened while in the Garden
of Gethsemane after the last supper and
before his arrest by the Romans he
underwent What's called the agony in the
garden he experienced such an intense
Terror of the pain and suffering he knew
he was about to receive that he sweated
blood so let's recap we've got two
things here the science of pain
traversing the body and going into the
brain and the science of what happens
when it starts being processed the first
intervention was to eliminate pain in
the course of applying medical knowledge
we did have like developing anesthesia
for surgeries in the early 1800s we knew
how to knock someone out you back him on
the head or drug them the problem is we
didn't know how long they'd be out when
they'd wake up or if they'd wake up at
all the solution was recreate
educational drug use hello please hit
that like button and let me thank
hellofresh for supporting vsauce2
relieving hunger pains with delicious
dinners has never been more convenient
thanks to hellofresh their seasonal
ingredients are picked at Peak ripeness
and travel from the farm to your
doorstep in less than seven days they've
got 40 recipes to choose from weekly
with options for even the pickiest
eaters and it's 25 percent less
expensive than takeout I ate pretty much
the same things for breakfast and lunch
every day so dinner is the time to
inject much needed Variety in my diet
and hellofresh takes the guesswork out
of deciding what to eat and it's always
a much better balanced meal than the two
pan fried hot dogs I'd probably eat on
my own so go to hellofresh.com and use
code 16 vsauce2 to get 16 free meals
plus free shipping that's hellofresh.com
and use code 16 vsauce2 for 16 free
meals plus free shipping okay
Joseph Priestly who discovered oxygen
synthesized nitrous oxide in 1772 it
became known as Laughing Gas experiments
used it to treat tuberculosis but the
British Gentry organized laughing gas
parties where they inhaled it and
stumbled around like giggling idiots the
same thing happened with ether Michael
Faraday hosted ether parties called Jags
and eventually someone noticed that when
party goers injured themselves while
Under the Influence they were not in
pain it's refinement for use since
surgery came later and the same was true
for derivatives of cocaine which was
found to Be an Effective local
anesthetic lidocaine novocaine and all
the other canes were developed as
replacements for cocaine because uh
cocaine proved to be kind of addictive
paracelsus the magnet scientist who I
mentioned in my madness of crowds video
dissolved opium extract in a solution he
called it laudanum which literally means
worthy of Praise there was morphine
which is seriously strong the Dutch had
a poppy paste called dupe which is where
we got the term dope and in 1897
scientists at Bayer developed aspirin so
there was that but until the middle of
the 20th century pain management was
pretty much the same as it was in Julius
Caesar's time before I explain what
happened consider that modern doctors
generally have three ways to deal with a
patient's pain eliminate the underlying
cause which is best treat the pain
itself or alter the patient's perception
of the pain 80 years ago that wasn't so
clear throughout World War II pain and
suffering was documented on a grand
scale across a range of cultures but
after the war tens of millions were
living with chronic pain some missing
limbs some with irreparably broken
bodies some with broken Minds some with
nagging injuries that prevented them
from resuming their past lives we'd
always dealt with pain but now we had a
lot of it we didn't know what to do and
even the obvious pain in battle didn't
always make sense John bonica is
considered the founder of the discipline
of pain medicine he couldn't understand
why three-fourths of these seriously
wounded men he treated during the
landing at anzio did not request
morphine and some were even happy happy
how do you smile when your leg gets
blown off Monica knew severe chronic
pain himself before the war he'd been a
famous professional wrestler named The
Masked Marvel and as he aged his body
never forgave him Monica concluded that
pain was not a simple question of will
or temperament and that it depended on
things like mood emotional status
cerebral functions anxiety levels and
more and that analgesia or any medical
intervention needed to respect the areas
of life outside of pain medicine at that
time did not respect the areas of life
outside of pain a 1956 article in Time
magazine called the new wave of overly
strong pain medications don't give a
damn pills because they seemed to wipe
out the personalities of too many who
took them painkillers flooded the
medical Marketplace and patients were
demanding relief at the same time the
same time the most widely accepted way
to deal with chronic pain was simply to
sever the nerves connected to it
including the broad use of Antonio a gas
moniz's lobotomy for which he won the
Nobel Prize the common practice was the
ice pick method where a long thin metal
pick was inserted above the eyeball and
gouged around one's frontal lobe It
generally worked but many lobotomy
patients continue to report their
chronic pain just that they didn't care
about it anymore
so the spectrum of dealing with pain in
the 1950s was zombie pills or brain
gouging to make the situation worse one
phrase became increasingly common in
medicine
malingerer someone who exaggerates their
pain to avoid the responsibilities of
daily life doctors had to identify
whether a patient's pain was even
legitimate before figuring out how to
treat it and the pharmaceutical industry
was just exploding pain management was a
total mess which turned out to be a good
thing in 1965 Ronald Balzac and Patrick
Wall processed the complexity of it all
to formulate the gate control theory of
pain in rejecting Descartes simplistic
bell ringer Theory they wrote pain is
not a fixed response to hurtful stimulus
its perception is modified by our past
experiences our expectation and more
subtly by our culture pain we now
believe refers to a category of complex
experiences not a single sensation
produced by a specific stimulus their
Theory came 20 years after the
conclusion of Humanity's greatest Global
sustained bout of pain and it was just
in time for pain to get political after
the war the desire to alleviate pain and
suffering led to sweeping welfare states
that could take care of the needy
governments were faced with impossible
questions whose pain is worthy of
support is all pain real how much pain
should we expect a normal person to
endure how do you define standards for
what hurts in the United States the pain
standard had been pretty Grim in 1937
the Supreme Court Judge learned and
wrote in tiber's reunited states that a
man may have to endure discomfort or
pain and not be totally disabled much of
the best work of Life Goes On under such
disabilities translation suck it up
buttercup yeah then everything changed
with Rosie page in 1963 the Supreme
Court heard Paige V celebreezie which
detailed Rosie's plight with pain she
claimed was a result of her job at a
manufacturing plant doctors were split
how real was her pain and to what degree
does the patient decide the ruling
shifted the entire concept of pain and
suffering if pain is real to the patient
the disability entitles the person to
statutory benefits if pain is real to
the patient the subjective was now worth
at least as much as the objective and is
that a good thing to someone in intense
pain that even Dr House can't diagnose
absolutely yes to a doctor who must
decide whether a patient can be
prescribed opiates without a significant
risk of developing abuse not really and
uh that's where we're at with pain in a
push and pull of the real and the
perceived and in a race with science to
figure it all out pain is a physical
sensation and an emotion and a problem
that 75 years ago would have been
addressed by an ice pick through the eye
socket now encompasses acute treatment
palliative care and a range of mental
health interventions but we still have
the same questions we've always had
should childbirth be painful and natural
or should we administer epidural
analgesia how much does giving Aid to
the suffering actually encourage them to
not get better how important is pain and
suffering to The Human Experience
Humanity has so much back pain because
our spines are designed to be horizontal
parallel to movement on the ground we've
got upright so fast that our bones
haven't caught up childbirth hurts so
much because our cranial size increased
so rapidly that women's bodies haven't
had time to accommodate our big baby
melons and pain
seven million years are direct ancestors
and ancient ancestors just had to Bear
it it's really only in the last 100 that
we've even faced the prospect of being
able to walk into a drugstore to relieve
it now we don't know what to do
we know that pain leads to suffering but
we aren't clear on how much it has to
in the 1962 film Lawrence of Arabia T.E
Lawrence stuns the other Soldiers by
extinguishing a match with his fingers
one of them tries it and shrieks that it
hurts then demands to know what the
trick is
to which Lawrence replies
the trick
is not minding that it hurts
and as always
thanks for watching
[Music]